considera la fórmula y es igual a 12
sobre p donde ye representa la
producción de zanahorias entonces quiere
presentar la producción de zanahorias se
representa la cantidad de zanahorias
esperadas
entonces se representa la cantidad de
zanahorias esperadas y p representa la
cantidad de plantas que representa la
cantidad de plantas selecciona la unidad
de medida apropiada para la producción
de zanahorias entonces la clave quiere
darse cuenta que podemos manejar a las
unidades de la misma manera que podemos
manejar variables algebraicas entonces
bueno por ejemplo aquí si decimos que
nuestra producción será dos veces la
cantidad de zanahorias esperadas
dividida por el número de plantas
entonces nuestras unidades serán si por
ejemplo ponemos números vamos a poner
números a solo para hacer esto más
interesante entonces digamos que se es
igual a 10 anna orias y estoy inventando
estos números
estas cantidades entonces digamos que p
es igual a 30 plantas entonces usando
esta fórmula tenemos que que es igual a
2 por 10 zanahorias
sobre p
que es igual a 30 plantas
entonces 2 por 10 zanahorias eso es
igual a 20 zanahorias así que en el
numerador podemos escribir 20 zanahorias
dividido entre 30 plantas y eso será
igual a puedes dividir los números
entonces tenemos 20 entre 30 eso es dos
tercios así que las unidades serán
zanahorias sobre plantas hojas
zanahorias entre plantas muy bien y una
vez más todo lo que hice fue solo ver
cuáles serían las unidades de medida
para la producción de zanahorias ajá
entonces bueno podemos ver que las
unidades de medida serán zanahorias
sobre plantas y puse estos números aquí
sólo para hacerlo un poco más un poco
más interesante y puedes notar que
estamos manipulando algebraica mente o
matemáticamente manipulando los números
al igual que a las unidades y así cuando
cuando queremos encontrar las unidades
de medida apropiadas para la producción
de zanahoria vemos
que son zanahorias sobre plantas
esta es la unidad de medidas apropiadas
para la producción de zanahorias
entonces bueno puedes ver que no son
zanahorias sobre plantas al cuadrado no
no no no este éste hubiera sido el caso
si si estuviera elevado al cuadrado la p
tampoco este caso hubiera dado el
indicado porque observa plantas por raíz
de zanahorias eso pasaría así tenemos
por ejemplo la raíz aquí ajá y
estuviéramos multiplicando por p pero
bueno no es así pero lo que puedes
observar es que esta constante el 2 no
afecta a las unidades porque lo que sí
importa es cómo estas variables se
relacionan entre sí estamos tomando la
variable ci y estamos dividiendo la
entre p ajá entonces cualquiera que sea
las unidades de c las vamos a dividir
entre las unidades entre las unidades
para p y así obtenemos la unidad de
medida para la producción de zanahorias
zanahorias sobre plantas